lo que comenzó como una marcha pacífica
en la ciudad portuaria griega de
tesalónica se convirtió en una violenta
muestra de desafío los manifestantes
vandalizaron fachadas de edificios se
enfrentaron a la policía y lanzaron
cócteles el dolor tras el accidente de
tren más mortífero de Grecia da paso a
la rabia las marchas también recorrieron
la ciudad de la risa cerca del lugar del
accidente sin inmutarse por la lluvia en
la capital los manifestantes llevaron su
indignación a la sede de la compañía
ferroviaria Helen los manifestantes
afirman que la sangre de los casi 60
muertos en el choque frontal del martes
por la noche entre un tren de pasajeros
y otro de mercancías está en sus manos
y el gobierno actual y el anterior
comparten la responsabilidad ignoraron
las peticiones de los empleados que
semanalmente y diariamente planteaban
sus preocupaciones sobre cuestiones de
salud y seguridad y la posibilidad de un
accidente grave
la dimisión del ministro de transportes
griego el miércoles no ha bastado por
aplacar la ira de los manifestantes por
un accidente que según el gobierno se
debió a un error humano los disturbios
se producen mientras los trabajadores
del ferrocarril vuelven a abandonar sus
puestos de trabajo el viernes tras
mantener una huelga de 24 horas el día
anterior afirman que la tragedia ha
puesto de manifiesto la incapacidad de
las autoridades para modernizar el
sistema ferroviario que achacan a la
falta de financiación los años de crisis
financiera en Grecia obligaron a
privatizar el operador ferroviario del
país que fue comprado por la empresa
pública italiana pero viene de los tato
italiane en 2017 a pesar de ello los Crí
ticos sostienen que los trenes en Grecia
siguen siendo deficientes con gran parte
de los trabajos clave de control
ferroviario todavía operados manualmente